welcome today's episode is sponsored by
manscaped we love little play
thank you very much hello I like to
start it off with a bang we are
sponsored by manscaped and a very
exciting announcement yellow was
something we've been working on in
secret for a long time we're super
excited yes it's the teddy fresh
spongebob squarepants collaboration
coming together tomorrow at 10 a.m.
Thursday 10 a.m. PST and I'm telling you
this [ __ ] is gonna move fast fast fast
so you better be waiting if you want
this because it is going to be gone I
think so fast but we got the color-block
hoodies with the spongebob and the teddy
bear patch or embroidery right we've got
long sleeve shirts this is another is
the one that I'm wearing here we've got
shirts that's her do we have close-ups
it's super cool it said it's spongebob
and teddy bear patch on the t-shirt
beautiful beautiful lots of these shirts
we got the beanie with the Bob and the
bear this is the one that eel is wearing
it's spongebob it's just Teddy fresh
over the top about a boom bada bang
Bob's your uncle we also have so here's
another long-sleeve fanny pack
long-sleeve spongebob blowing bubbles
it's
the bear got him mm-hmm this is the bath
2020 there's another t-shirt we're
making steady for a spongebob oh this
one I really like it's like our classic
logo tee but with spongebob instead of
our bear this is this one that you was
wearing in pink
got him hat got him that's it so be on
our website tomorrow at 10 a.m. PST if
you want it because it is not gonna be
here for long
congratulations evil congratulations
everyone thank you very much
unfortunately PewDiePie could not make
it to today's episode I am working on
scheduling him for later this week so I
will keep you guys updated on the PD pie
situation but I'm really helping to get
him in here soon now Eva speaking of
spongebob you posted a photo on our way
to the office today promoting or miele
braiding really but but everything the
only thing anyone's talking about is
what is going on with this photo now
you'll notice that if you're looking at
this photo
Neela's legs appear to be that she's
standing straight up but in the in the
mirror it looks like her legs are
extremely split like what the what the I
don't know and I just was standing like
that I think it's the angle that looks
that makes it look like that but it's
not it's not photoshopped everyone
thinks it's Photoshop be honest
you took a motor I took the photo yeah I
don't know what to say
it looks photoshopped it's super weird
it's definitely is a curse or blessed I
don't know they say you look so angry I
like your style my happy face I need him
oh I don't see anyone nice rack what are
you talking about how dare you nice rack
Oh
anyway I'm referring to myself because I
said you had nice boobs yeah are you
saying no I don't think so I make maybe
some people think so
so I mean okay I don't know but I'm
coming off of a rough week on Instagram
so this was just kind of like continuing
the rough week that I've already had
mm-hmm what I finally passed 1 million
followers and I don't post a lot and so
it was a big milestone for me and then I
saw this awesome meme with Elon Musk and
I posted it and I I've been going down
ever since I posted it and followers she
lost 2,000 followers and she posted the
Elon Musk meme and you posted cringe
know generally Wow if you post grains
you lose subscribers dude that's the
rule
hey she got 150,000 likes on it got
really good engagement hmm so what do
you say to that Dan how many that's a
lot of likes how many subscribers did
she gain she ain't - 2 % there you go
that's it that's that's like the meat
you know that you think this is France
just that's what people saying if you
post cringy these subscribers I've never
heard that Daniel up with the memes man
what are you doing I'm already so
insecure about posting and it's like
okay great I just will not post at all
don't worry about these peas weird that
you I agree I don't know who are all
these hate maybe it was Instagram it was
a coincidence where they do this bird no
this is right after I posted that I
started losing started going down when
was your most recent post previous to
that whole thing yeah not too long ago
though no there are these people that
they're like i'm i'm so i only want
photos of Elah and theodore and now they
think i mean if there's a meme 2% of
your fan base on there were like [ __ ]
this I'm out maybe people are sick of
the getting sick of the Elan memes but
they unsubscribe it's not posted every
name come up with an explanation for I
mean we we have a situation that needs
explaining no it is a situation I'm
traumatized
and I'm a disaster you buzzing Photoshop
photos shitty memes I mean who would
want to follow you there okay so anyway
we've got drama Trisha Paytas is making
waves as our new bachelorette have we
we've gotten some interesting
applications already right Dan yeah
actually some you guys are actually
bringing the fire with this we're pretty
impressed I already have we already have
some favorites pulled and but keep
sending them in yeah guys if you want to
apply to date
Trisha as our Bachelorette in this
season remember to send your
applications to podcast at h3h3
productions com we are reviewing soon
you have another week I believe to
submit so I'm I'm super excited is gonna
be able ton of fun she's gonna come back
in here judge our applicants I want to
get someone like Shane because Shane
like them retweeted Shane Dawson and I
would love to get someone like that in
here to help us judge the Bachelorette
post right yeah
that's pretty epic speaking of The
Bachelorette I have to ask you you know
I noticed that in our last podcast
whoever the genius back there you
noticed that huh noticed think everybody
did don't like the 10,000 comments all
pointing it out okay hold on podcast so
whoever did this overlay said podcast at
h3h3 productions calm now sure it's only
a minor detail it's only the whole point
of the competition is for people to know
that email and submit things dan so
whose did this you know it was a you Dan
yes it was me because I was asking
I save too fast so do you think that
this just isn't important the email no
of course it was very embarrassing and I
apologize but but also I mean how many
people do you think really thought well
like I know their name is h3h3
productions but but the eye is in a
different place so I mean it's gotta be
that and are you a fan of the h3 product
on because that's what I'm reading Pro
Duquette on yeah Danvers you have a good
point then but you would be surprised
people go did I be well I was think I
was seeing comments it was like so is it
this right which I mean fair enough it
does say that but in my mind was like no
obviously it's yeah but they're like
well who could actually [ __ ] up a typo
when running and you need them like if
it was me I'd probably send it to both
fair enough and then and then it would
get through but not everyone has this
one has this beautiful mind we have been
inundated with applications so a good
amount of them are getting through you
know well who knows maybe her true
love's over there on podcast at HP
Patong Patong dan dan
produc atones I just love produc atones
this happened and were you just typing
too fast no I even double-checked it you
know that I when letters in the middle
of a word or flipped like that I'd have
a hard time noticing it somehow you ever
seen those things where it's like a
whole paragraph and all the letters
scrambled or whatever but you can still
totally read it yeah I mean that's what
it like I looked at it several times and
was like yep that's that's right and
just mm-hmm probe Duquette on Dan well
if we threw up the graphic a moment ago
when you were talking about it it's
correct now please if you submitted to
predacons last week to podcast a t-38
reproduction yes this has been a week of
typos I've been pointing out lots of
typos to people and I like some
not here at Eddie fresh either cracks
the lips over the minutes but I find it
funny because I'm not even from here
well you have a you a your very detailed
focused person it's true and you know
what
Neela crack the whip on a new hire and
it's [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of me
he loved rules with the iron fist man
everybody knows not to cross her because
she doesn't tolerate [ __ ] doesn't
tolerate anything less than perfection
that's right it's true
dude this guy out of that roof hate to
be that guy
I don't get chewed out by you that hard
have ice I've escaped her wrath I think
for the most part well you're my husband
yeah but still you don't do mistakes eat
them in I have Intel that you are sick
this week any and why are you always
sick uh where'd that come from by the
way did I tell you that yeah don't worry
about it I have I have Intel we gotta
walk that okay what do you what is it
yeah I'm still very confused what's
wrong with you why were you sick this
weekend you know like we're Jewish we
get a memo don't worry about who told me
you tell me what's going on with you
because you're always safe you talking
to the wild card no don't worry about it
do you think I would let him just tell
me what's wrong with you I don't know
I'm feeling all out of it right now I
don't know think I'm dying or something
I don't know are you
I've been chugging the water are you
feeling like fever you're just feeling
fatigued in general yeah very tired very
sleepy hmm are you depressed no I'm
happy I'm sure you're good you're have I
just have been really tired last few
days so Rana are you getting home do you
get eight hours of sleep uh try yeah mmm
I sleep I sleep I sleep good when you're
a schedule yeah well tell me go to bed
usually uh by like 10:00 or something
holy [ __ ] what
like like a like heard quick you wake up
at like 6:00
no I sleep later than that Oh see wait
maybe you're sleeping too much cuz I
know that can cause it's yeah if you
oversleep like what time you wake up if
you go to bed at 10:00 maybe like 8
o'clock so you're sleeping 10 an hour 10
hours is ok 8 to 10 I mean 10 is who's
got the time to slip down hours
that's a good question that kind of
comments pretty nice you guys to try it
that's good I mean I mean I'd rather
live my life try eight normally if I
can't hate its beauty might you'd rather
begin those criticals on Diablo yeah
three trillion bro don't hate yeah well
you know I'd like to have some time to
enjoy myself
Ian tennis too early for a young guy
he's a little [ __ ] all right I'll stay
up later thank but I just well I want to
understand why you're feeling fatigued
because I obviously I want you to feel
good and I want you to perform at your
peak you're on the show
diet diet what are you eating are you
doing some crazy diet no diets all right
hold on are you eating healthy yeah I
eat a lot of fish a lot of fish burritos
those are like my Jewish grandparents
are you eating well sleep well he says
he's so what do you want our life
switcher is not gonna perform it is yeah
I understand this is it are you I mean
are you worried about how are things was
with your girlfriend everything is
groovy my man sound like the Prophet guy
Marcus yes like a reference yeah sorry
my man my man gave in so when you were
sick this weekend would you have a fever
did you have a cold or you were just
feeling fatigued just a lot of headaches
headaches that's not good just tired
ache behind my did you sit like drinking
coffee all this I don't know something
that I don't drink coffee
are you worried are you considering
seeing a doctor I mean that doesn't
sound good no
I'm fine mm-hmm you told the guys you're
sick you having headaches behind the
eyes and you're like that is that the
spies wait what I didn't what guys
didn't he tell who who who's the inside
info that you got here come on fess up
to it there's no dude I'm telling you I
have informants don't worry money and
that's not what's that question here I
want to make sure it's okay all right I
gotta keep a close eye on you well
actually we talked to IANS mother your
mother my mother's been calling yeah
she's been calling cheese
all right well feel better I mean take
care of yourself you know okay I'll give
you an illustration well yeah I'm
usually ill I'm ill a lot do you know
but but I'm being serious throughout
your life do you find yourself like sick
a lot or is that is this a reoccurring
thing throughout your time on earth I
don't know you have allergies or
something like you have some kinda
probably yeah that's probably what's
going on
and you're being a troll do you have a
chronic illness or some of some kind uh
not that I'm aware of
okay I mean I just don't know why you
try to make a joke out of this when I'm
having genuine concern for your health I
don't think well as long as I don't have
current or anything I'm cool I don't
think you I don't think it's got here
yet but you by the sound of it would be
the first one to get it oh I got it baby
all right yeah I'm trying to include you
in the show but like oh he's got a car
Oh what the [ __ ] why you have a curse
what are you just waiting for this it's
starting to sound like a sound bite
machine yeah I appreciate that thank you
I'm just I'm trying to include you in
the show and I don't know if you're
doing stick or if you're trying to
engage in a serious conversation
trolling and I don't appreciate it
that's the best place to be won't even
talk to him like I try to talk to him I
tried to include him in the show I like
the whole that dynamic here on the show
is what makes it interesting for me
we've got three guys back there a bunch
of characters and the two of us in here
I'm trying to make the show interesting
I'm trying to enrich the dynamic but Ian
refuses to and gay they after all I've
done for him a given purpose I gave him
a job I gave him a girlfriend a love
life everything I built him up to the
man he is today and I don't know what I
do to deserve this disrespect like I
genuinely want to know how he is that
I'm getting stick I don't understand
what do you have to say about that
I'm not Joe I'm not joking hmm I think I
offer a good balance I think I'm
differentiating from the two comedians
next to me over here we're offering a
good office violet ready Ladue grew with
me I agree with you because we need the
truth I want a genuine right I want
genuine conversation not looking for
snick I do this stick you do you answer
the questions I asked you that's how
this works right you look that's right
thank you
somebody backs me up fun I mean all
right let's move on because Ian's
putting everyone to sleep we talked
about everything I just did a whole I
mean everything you guys we'll see you
at the Capri four manscaped I did seven
minute monologue about how I nicked my
shaft but but we have to move on because
he's slowing the show down yeah a little
disrespectful mildly alright let's just
move on because I'm getting upset
we got the goop candle finally now I
have predicted that this candle didn't
exist because I said it sold out
immediately at $75 I feel like it's just
a marketing ploy but I'm wrong here's
the candle people actually bought it and
actually what sold out so says this
smells like my vagina it's got pictures
of a vaginal looking flower I guess what
kind of flower is that I don't know
anyway it's so it's a pretty flower that
looks like a batch okay let's open the
candle let's get right to it so this is
Gwyneth Paltrow's goop
smells like my vagina now I'm just gonna
tell you straight out the bag that
smells like a candle I got scammed out
of $75 what a [ __ ] marketing ploy
this is [ __ ]
it smells like a [ __ ] candle okay it
doesn't smell any different
like a scented candle or just yeah it's
a perfumed candles good I think I think
you're missing the joke
to be honest with ya call ahead I think
it's just like a meme you know like her
vagina smells good yeah cuz there's all
these conversations about like the smell
I never smelled a vagina like that right
but she's like sticking it there it's
like this I didn't want to smell her
vagina or anyone that will have this in
their house this smells like my vagina
well I don't know I mean I was really
expecting something of what like more of
a pungent odor I think if you were to
make it that's fun and by the way on the
bottom there's a stick these [ __ ]
idiots there's a sticker over a sticker
like this was originally real and I
think you can see through it I got to
peel that off there's a sticker under
the sticker which makes me think they
just repurpose this candle not exactly
yeah that's right papa I don't like when
she's I mean I like her as an actress
but this whole goop thing is just so off
the deep end
yeah we talked did we talk about the
crystal handling segment on the goop
show the crystal healing I think we are
know energy healing
yeah the energy healing we talked about
a little bit yeah yeah yes that was
really disturbing oh he was getting the
sticker up what are you seeing is it
just the same thing okay
some dumb-dumb put it on tight right I
don't like it I don't like it so should
we light it I mean yeah let's light it
so I feel like I just got scammed at 75
yeah I mean ultimately I was expecting
something a little more interesting than
that
you think you could just put our label
smells like my vagina well maybe my
butthole smells like perfume exactly it
doesn't so here's what we're doing I
don't know if I have guys update you
we had joke that I wanted to make a
smells like my butthole candle to combat
smells like my vagina candle and an
aroma scent company got ahold of us and
they said hey we work for like a theme
park so that there's serious company
that makes aromas you know it like
Disneyland when you're doing Sauron you
and they squirt like I'll roll my in
your face yeah so these are these guys
they do specialty aroma you said I want
one that smells like I want one smells
like [ __ ] but I'm don't mean farts
you understand if it suppose like farts
you [ __ ] that what it needs to smell
like is a sharp sweaty mm-hmm deodorant
II taint you know it's not it's worse
than fart it's different
mm-hmm I said look if somebody has to
come down here and put their nose my
[ __ ] so be it I'm capturing that
smell so we're gonna get our own
fragrance we're gonna do brown wax and
we're gonna sell it for $75 and it's
gonna say this smells like my butthole
great do you think will sell out yes I
do
I think good collectible how many are
you thinking like will be available I
don't think I'll make that many you know
yeah because I don't think there's that
much demand for it if I'm being honest I
mean I want one that's already one one
percent there you go would you guys buy
something like that for a gag I $75 for
$75 yeah after my price well I'm sorry
but no I would not do that I think
there's at least a hundred people out
there that want that limited rhyme I
don't want to discourage anybody but how
many good I mean I don't want to get
stuck with a roomful of buttholes is a
lot for cats yeah that's how much you
pay for this I gotta make my money back
well then we only need to sell one
duality I don't I got a I got a develop
it right
I got a pay I got
there's a lot of expenses here because
the whole supply chain yeah I'd buy it
exactly don't say anything
even would you buy it wait do you want
me to I wouldn't buy it no okay why did
I ask you but if this was Canas armpit
if it was Kanye's about home would you
buy it
oh I'd freaking eat it are you
disenchanted with Kanye are you still
all in on Kanye I've tapped out a little
bit he seems to wound down there so hear
as much about him anymore
yeah notice that I am low and is there
another person who's become the object
of your affection and obsession yeah
it's uh ethan klein he stands yes
there's nothing real about anything he
says that's a problem I'm not gonna lie
who are you obsessed with their.you
obsessed with any artist do you replace
Kanye no okay thank you see how hard was
that are people gonna think I'm being
too hard on you definitely you're gonna
get a lot of comments yeah I'll say
right now everyone leave Ethan alone
it's fine there you go me perfect do you
really think that people are gonna be
upset at me for such insolence well just
it previous times that you've been harsh
on in there's a lot of people sticking
up for him so I'm just going off a bit
past experiences well go ahead and
delete all those comments they don't
erase don't erase don't do that we also
don't Photoshop Instagram posts hmm hmm
I love you why do I have to even clarify
it's all we're all just goofing around
here but let's move on I know I don't
need to an old 20 minutes on how I and
Dan I told you I cautioned you not to I
love the end by the way Dan means the
greatest Dan yes yes sir
I cautioned you not to watch this clip
did you watch not watch it I did not
watch it now
was a good little boy good so we found
this now you guys all know that we're
huge mega fans of 90 day fiancé the
latest season was a huge flop we didn't
watch it yeah we didn't care but what
showed up on my homepage was a preview
for this upcoming season of 90 day
fiancé called before the 90 days and
what I saw was something that truly
excited me and made me I just can't wait
for the next season look at this
character this is the grip I mean first
of all just get a glimpse of him he's
like a he's like a chubby dude with no
wait my dude okay in a few days I'm
getting ready to get on a plane and go
meet rose the love of my life for the
very first time so it's some like 20
year old it's been torn I feel like a
Filipino looking girl in Asian very cute
young girl and he looks to be like at
least 50 and really just a mess so much
yeah he's prepping he's like I'm trying
to assimilate for the very first time
I'm super excited because he just
grabbed a bought a train a bottle man to
ask rose to marry me you watching the
few damn ayo in his hair since I met
Rose I want to look young for her so I
have been dyeing my hair and it
irritates my scalp smoother Zac we gotta
do the mayo challenge for you I'm
looking for some [ __ ] to hydrate my hair
so what's the best way should we have
Zack do it here or film himself doing at
home cuz he's gonna have to wash it out
make a wash out the sink yeah I feel
like that'd be very difficult I think so
Zack if you will do what he's doing put
manis in your hair and then and then
document the process and we can play it
on the show okay I will do that okay
great
get your girlfriend to help you film or
something she will and then because I
want to see being applied I want to see
you you have to sit with it shower and
then give me like the updates if it
worked or not okay
if you smell if the smell of mayonnaise
and later successor etc how long do you
have to let it sit though
well he'll see he lets it sit for a
while you'll see mushes I'm
self-conscious of my physical appearance
because Rose is 31 years younger than me
I smell like an egg salad sandwich but
it really really works I just want to
look young for Rose so you step the
mayonnaise in his hair you put a bag on
his head and now he's got a glass of
wine like the producers when they saw
this guy's face they're like oh it's
time printing money's yes when you see
this come in Eadie 54 they're like oh
but then when they see his like who his
fiancee is like oh my god
then I'll let Sunday show up at his
house they're doing mayonnaise in his
hair Oh God
see ed is in San Diego well if we could
get him on the show I wonder how they
found him I feel like they went really
like they sent everyone on a search cuz
the last season what was kind of shitty
so bad yeah the worst unwatchable I
stopped watching same with the bachelor
too so the bachelor I agree is just way
off this season and I'm gonna I'm gonna
watch the fantasy suites
[Music]
because there's one really crazy girl
that I'm that I'm interested in seeing
what develops with her but Pete is the
worst bachelor of all time and I and I I
know he's human could have just been
like a cardboard cutout all right right
here would be the same this show would
be the same thing all the girls being
caddy and dramatic and he literally has
no personality you know I could have
told him not to pick Pete I was so
shocked and they picked Pete are they're
gonna pick that black guy Mike right and
I was like oh he's gonna be the first
black bachelor to I was like oh this is
cool he's got it I like him and then
they wouldn't ever be like I know
apparently there's never been a black
guy and says it great that's obvious
they're gonna choose him and he'll be
great they go with Pete
I guess the hook with Pete is that he
has a real job most people are totally
unemployed he's a pilot
but unfortunately pilot doesn't give you
any personality at all and cheer
anything I can't stand him he's the
voice so over thank you watching the
seasons we have no shows like 90 day and
a bachelor both suck I can't yeah he
just he's a [ __ ] wet noodle he's got
no persona dryness it's really it shows
good one healer it's not even been
cooked it just goes to show you that all
these girls are in love with him it's
like it's just the competition you have
this scarcity or it's like there's one
guy in the world and they're all
fighting for him so you'd they'll yeah
mental and it's like he is proof that I
mean I don't think anyone needs any
convincing but it's like these girls
could not possibly be in love with him
he is so unappealing they go I have to
admit that today I finally am ready to
tell you that I have fallen in love it's
like it please you guys have talked for
a commutative like 20 minutes I'd rather
see adhere as bad
that would be [ __ ] amazing I can't
wait to see what else add is up to you
know look at take that in drinking wine
with the mayonnaise take that all in
HeLa God leave look at this I'm gonna
wash this again he's put he's like
coloring his hair you know when you go
he's like all official about it since I
met Rose I I want to look young for her
dude that's just so I have been dying
right there and it irritates my scalp so
I found out that mayonnaise makes it
smoother and have you tried conditioner
have you thought about something like
that
God straight to maids
oh my goodness and then he goes and
watch TV and drinks wine with mani Singh
who's here dude
what about I did what about just
moisturizer just put moisturizer
yeah did I remember once while when I
was in Israel we were waiting out like
the DMV or something yeah and there's
some young dude there who had a bottle
of moisturizer and he kept he had he
kept putting moisturizer and it's not
gel or anything get a bottle a huge
bottle of moisturizer and he kept just
[ __ ] it was great I never seen
anything like it
oh we got to go to break once weird
let's go to break we'll be right back
do you do you guys backstage trim your
pubes I sure do yeah absolutely
yep yeah you know I didn't start
trimming my pubes until like well after
college and I even have people
commenting on it and if some reason it
never occurred to me they go by the way
this response about manscaped
but I'll get to that they go one girl
went wow you have a lot of pubic hair
I thought somewhere where she was like
complimenting me I was like it's crazy I
know but it never but she was obviously
telling me to trim my pubes but I didn't
it didn't occur to me I feel like it's a
generational thing where people always
trimming their pubes I think even in my
age bracket it was be considerate to
trim it because my pubes were like
insane it was like a huge like they were
long as my penis did society I mean it
could be about Trent pubes I think it's
the consumption of porn is like I say I
was taking in porn since I was like
[ __ ] - I'm not bragging it's just a
matter of fact it's bug that told my
therapist that once and he's like has a
whole nother Pandora's box Ethan because
this is the weirdest of a Dorito ever
but I'll get there because my dad had a
stash of porn have I told the story on
the podcast
these have a stash of VHS porn tapes in
his closet that he would stash there
like hundreds of them and me and my
brother we were home alone all the time
so only it was only natural that we got
into those I was watching like and like
my dad you know he's a sick man he had
like the most [ __ ] up porn you can
imagine though so well you pretty okay I
mean you're not like a perv
I try my absolute best to suppress the
demons with them
so but I guess Lauren is not like the
devil no porn is not a double it's just
that I you shouldn't start watching it
the young age that I did but back to
pubes well I started shaving my pubes
with and I'm not gonna lie I used my
beard trimmer because I would shower
afterwards so I was like you know this
is I I acknowledge this is disgusting I
shaved my pubes I'm gonna shave my beard
with it I acknowledge that it's gross
but on the other hand I'm gonna take a
shower afterwards and I really have
nothing better
manscaped is like this is more than we
asked for this is everything we asked
for a personal endorsement but I'm
getting to that this is more than I ever
dreamed of getting a little too personal
they should be paying me double and so I
acknowledge that was disgusting but I
didn't have a better way and the other
problem is that I've got I've got hairs
all up my dick shaft it's disgusting and
so that's very sensitive skin I find the
word shaft like so funny it's not good
nothing about it's good it's all bad and
so I was trying to get those hairs down
and what was happening is that I kept
nicking my skin and there's nothing
worse first of all feeling that pain up
then you see a little blood it's like
there's nothing worse in the world a
razor blade forget about it it also
happened to my balls I tried to shave my
balls Nick
skin and I'm just telling you it's a do
you guys have a problem with that I mean
it's it's been known to happen but you
know you you you're very careful you
know but I could time it happened to me
so often that I started to get like
what's the word scabs no not Jesus den
now I started to get really traumatized
so I was no longer getting that close
shave that I needed cuz I was being so
cautious that I was basically just I
wasn't getting doing the job
satisfactory and so when manscaped came
into my life you've got this beautiful
handheld razor somehow they figured it
out
that it's got this like soft blade it's
made of some special material I'm trying
to find out where it is yadda yadda
yadda we've got the
cutting-edge ceramic blade to prevent
manscaping accidents and so they've got
like a perfect guard length the ceramic
blade and I'll tell you what else they
got they have an LED light so when you
turn it on it flashes it lights your way
and I and I confidently went and shaved
down all my pubes the perfect length
down my shaft or under my balls
I even ventured into the gooc grundle if
you will and tell them that down a
little bit and I have to say that it was
a beautiful wonderful experience I'm so
glad that I have my manscaped 3.0
because I'm feeling my pubes are unfair
and frankly speaking I mean let's be
frank it it's better trimmed right yeah
yeah I mean it gets so crazy it's like
it's just so so I just want to first of
all tell you guys from a life of
experience that you definitely do want
to trim and I think that man escapes is
the way to do it because first of all
you don't forget pubic smell on your
face by doing a shaving a beard trimmer
and the beard trimmer is not even good
you don't even want that okay that's it
that's all I have to say so you can
subscribe when you purchase the new
perfect package 3.0 kit at manscape comm
you get the biggest bang for your buck
subscribers get a new replacement blade
refill for your lawnmower trimmer
deliver to your door every three months
making sure your trimmer always stays
fresh and clean for a limited time
subscribers get not one but two free
gifts the shed travel bag 39 value and
the path to did high-performance anti
shaving manscaped boxer-briefs
it's also something here about crop
purdue preserver and anti chafing ball
deodorant I want ball deodorant that's
up to you but I find that those are our
I find that those are counterproductive
ball deodorants
I just take a shower what the [ __ ]
wrong with you it's like I don't like
scented trash bags too
you can't just spray a dude don't that's
the word yeah it's it's worse it makes
it work because it yes it's like putting
a breeze on a pile of diarrhea it's like
that doesn't that didn't help at all but
you know I'll let you make that decision
for yourself but I do endorse the blade
you got the free gifts this is a perfect
package for your perfect package get
twenty five twenty percent off plus free
shipping with the code h3h3 at manscape
comm do yourself a favor and always use
the right tool for the job get 20% off
and free shipping with code h3h3 at
manscape comm that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape calm and use code
h3h3
your partner your body and your balls
and your shafts I added will thank you
we are back I hope you guys enjoyed my
seven minute long monologue about
manscaping I just want to tell you guys
before we move on can egg salad sandwich
but it really really works it really
really works okay moving right along
we've got poor old Joe man Joe Biden is
really his brain is just melting in his
poor old school and I wish him well
he's a public servant he's had a long
hard life ups and down and I was you
know but damn like we've talked about
Joe a lot here so I feel it's only right
to continue the dialogue that being said
I just feel sad for Joe at this point
you're the ones that sent Barack Obama
the presidency and I have a simple
proposition here I'm here to ask you for
your help
where I come from you don't get far
unless you ask my name is Joe Biden I'm
a Democratic candidate for the United
States Senate look me over like we see
helped out if not both the other by give
me a look though okay that's all I
really got to say to you I'm up he says
my name is Joe Biden right for a
Democratic Senate yeah then he says have
a look if you like what you see if you
don't like it vote for the other Biden
I think he meant candidate hmm but he
said vote for the other behind him nine
state Senate look me over you like we
see help out if not vote the other by
give me a look oh yeah yeah yeah he's
just really he's trying to really hold
like yeah hold together but it's just at
I mean look at sad at that age you're
[ __ ] just starts to slip it happens for
different people at different ages you
know but he's slipping man there's no
question about it I think he just had a
lot of tragedy in his life and that
stuff really aid you it's very very
difficult like his son recently passing
away you know that kind of [ __ ] it's
hard and that's all I have to say about
that um I do not see him winning you
know he's way behind now now he has no
chance I just wonder at what point is it
just a waste of time you know just quit
I think it's coming up because this this
week there's another vote and like what
is it South Carolina something correct
which is the one that for the last year
and a half we've been hearing is he's
unbeatable in because he has I guess
here's a lot of black support right and
so he's and I guess there's a lot of bad
people in South Carolina so he's hoping
that here's a strong showing after that
is Super Tuesday and then there's no
doubt about that
because Super Tuesday is like I don't
know 12 states including Texas in
California all vote on the same day and
so at that point you really you can
really tell thing is California and
Texas are heavy heavy Hispanic and the
Hispanics love Bernie he has like locked
down the Hispanic vote it's crazy and I
think he's just gonna sweep he's just
gonna continue to sweep yo by the way I
voted yeah you lose first time voting so
she's wearing it with pride do you have
any concerns about Bernie Sanders I mean
I just feel like if
wins it would be really interesting to
see what someone like him can actually
accomplish because these ideas to me
sound great I mean it's everything that
I would want to see happen and is it
true Dan correct me if I'm wrong does he
say that billionaire should not exist I
mean yeah maybe not explicitly now I
think you maybe even explicitly said
that so do you agree that billionaires
should not exist I don't really that's a
very strong statement like who how do
you decide like that's what you know
what I mean you wanted Aang and I even
saw him there and the names that you
could pick on I was like what about it
for young but I wish because he had the
best solution he's like I don't need to
raise taxes I just say the tax these
rich tech companies that don't even pay
tax yes it was gonna do a VAT tax
solution was dirty you would understand
what a bad tax is man that's what he
said taxi but he said that he would tax
like the big companies like Amazon
within also and also that you would get
money for like your data things like
that that no one is even talking about
yeah I mean on that level sure yeah I
mean he had a lot to say about the tech
industry that nobody else was talking
about he was not gonna raise taxes and
he definitely didn't say that
billionaires shouldn't exist
I guess that is kind of a dangerous
statement I voted for Bernie by the way
but statements like that are a little
concerning because I mean how like how
do you decide how many billions somebody
can have how do you decide what's too
successful I mean while I agree that
people like Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates
have way too much money at the same time
these are guys that came up with great
ideas that made all of our lives better
and they yeah you have to accede to it
no problem with that as long as there's
proper proper like systems to make sure
that they actually paid to rise and
there isn't a loophole for someone who's
making so much money because it's it's
so weird how is someone at that level
not pay taxes that's insane that
that's where I'm tired I want to make
sure that if somebody who is worth 130
billion dollars is paying half of that
axes like all of us are I paid 50
percent taxes every year I don't think
Jeff Bezos should be paying any less
than that mm-hmm so that that concerns
me but to say that billionaires
shouldn't exist is kind of like a
dangerous statement like what does that
mean I don't like how he demonizes
billionaires because they're ultimately
I mean like there's just a lot to unpack
there yeah look what do you what are you
saying they're inherently evil
billionaires how do you decide like dude
what are you taking away you know Bernie
Sanders as Michael Bloomberg pointed out
has three houses is do we decide people
shouldn't have three houses see this is
okay I know what you're getting cynical
okay whatever I'm believing no but
listen yeah I know he has a house in
Washington DC he has a house in Vermont
and he has like a cabin I know it's not
like a house but the point is Dan that
who's to decide how many houses somebody
could have if you're gonna decide who
what's a billionaire our people not
allowed to have three houses
I mean we're putting some measure well I
I do feel like he demonizes billionaires
and it's a slippery slope like - what -
[ __ ] - making these judgment calls
- what I don't know - anything bad
everything bad that can happen what what
does that mean well I agree with Ethan
the it's it's this point of view that
like billionaires are evil yeah
billionaires aren't inherently evil I
mean now they're not necessarily
inherently evil but here just to expand
on that a little bit I mean the reason
that I find Bloomberg trying to make
that jab about how many houses he has
completely absurd is that Bernie Sanders
has three houses yet which is far more
than the average American whatever hope
to own in their life right Bernie
Sanders has a couple of million dollars
this is all about hey look here no but
it doesn't matter
yeah he's agreed amazing just how no a
billion dollars really
I know how much your billion dollars is
dead that's not the point I can wrap my
head around it I know that Bernie
Sanders isn't rich like I mean he's
wealthy but he's not like rich right
he's he's worked Bernie Sanders has
worked I agree this characterization
that he's rich is stupid I agree with
you he's worth a long illustrious career
and he has a couple million dollars of
net worth that he deserves that he's
earned over life from work he's not rich
no one is yeah I agree that
characterization is [ __ ] but the
point is if you're gonna say billionaire
shouldn't exist how much work how are we
preventing that Dan but tax on them
oh okay so then what so then once you're
worth 999 million then every single
extra dollar goes to the government what
does it mean yeah I mean FDR wanted to
put a hundred percent tax yeah that was
a wartime tax doesn't work
well I mean I feel like it wasn't Oliver
sent some problems that it wasn't a
hundred percent but it was very high it
was like 98 percent yeah I mean close
enough right it was a wartime right now
we are flourishing
this isn't wartime I just I personally
just why you like this because I don't
know because I think we're barreling
towards self-destruction this plan is
gonna die in the next like 50 years if
we don't make huge changes and you know
it might require something on the scale
of a mobilization like we had to do in
World War two you know ah ha sorry later
but yeah that that you can do that with
that was the end the engine of the
economy is what is driving us towards
oblivion right now I mean that that's
billionaires anything is also companies
that are being just completely well I
mean obviously he's talking about taxing
those well I think dude systematically
I'm for attack saying all this stuff the
government is spending sorry good I just
we started with the conversation about
if a billionaire should exist I still
think that that is not the right
question and I have no problem with
billionaires existing yeah that
statement I mean it's weird it
contradicts kind of a lot of what it
means our our economy means
and there's a lot of other fundamental
issues we can look at I mean first of
all tech companies aren't paying taxes
we are spending all of like half of our
budget on military we are wasting tons
of money
bloated money on like Medicare for old
people paying [ __ ] drug companies
insane amounts of money I mean the
government can do a lot more saying
billionaire shouldn't exist is just it's
just a blanket statement it doesn't mean
anything and the thing is dangerous
because it villain eise's billion yeah
what you can do is implement a lot of
systems within the government to reduce
emissions to tax corporations to do all
this kind of [ __ ] to invest in
infrastructure I mean you're they are
not they're not the sole reason for by
the way I see a lot of them can be very
destructive because they have a lot of
power they can Lobby the government
influence decisions but some
billionaires aren't they're not all evil
I mean the very nature being a
billionaire does not make you inherently
evil and a statement like that I think
can be taken the wrong way by fanatics
billionaire shouldn't exist I disagree
you know it's a lot of money but some
guys have really good ideas like I mean
Jeff Bezos he's he's so [ __ ] rich I
mean just well just imagine if he
actually got taxed like he's supposed to
he wouldn't have as much money he still
be rich as [ __ ] though but dude Amazon
has changed the war the whole world I
mean that guy achieved umbra dick he's
like you know Henry Ford of the modern
day
he's revolutionized the whole [ __ ]
planet so I mean a guy like that sure he
deserves his what his success mm-hmm I
mean
I just I really think it's all about how
you how you make them pay back to people
like yank is all about that's it that's
for me that's what it's all about like
tech companies should pay us for the
data mm-hmm
Amazon should pay a fee you know look
ultimately the government needs a
certain amount of money to do its job
and if it's not getting enough money
that's one thing and there's certainly
like huge swaths a part of the economy
that are not paying that of people that
are making extraordinary amount of money
and not paying enough to the government
that I agree with mm-hmm
but I mean to say the billionaire's
shouldn't exist is a problem I don't
like that statement I think it rocks
it's part of why I like them well I
think it's I think I like in front I
like in first the health care education
but what do you think it rocks because I
believe in that so you think that a guy
who has made a company as prolific as
Amazon once he's worth 999 million
dollars every dollar over that should be
taxed straight to the government or how
does it work well I mean if we're just
like in medicine I'd prefer a preventive
approach like perhaps playing your
employees a living wage you know sharing
the success of your company with the
workers that actually generate all of
that wealth instead of hoarding it so
let's say he does all that but still
he's making he's still gonna about to
make that extra dollar I mean you know
how like you understand taxes it's a
progressive tax rate it's not like it's
gonna take all of his money but what
about someone like Elon Musk who with
his billions of dollars is doing
something that the government and other
private citizens like nobody else can do
what he's doing he has literally
invented he is popular as a mainstream
electric vehicles that are improving the
environment changing the world bringing
this new sustainable energy to the
mainstream he couldn't do that if he
wasn't a billionaire he put all his
whole fortunate stick to accrue to make
Tesla does an interesting one I mean
yeah that's true but I mean on the other
hand some of his other ventures like
SpaceX and everything I while I
appreciate that he's doing it it
honestly makes me kind of sad because
there was a time when you know we did
all of those things publicly and
extremely successfully and I mean SpaceX
but where all their accomplishments I
mean it all right but to this day SpaceX
has done have they done anything that
NASA didn't do yes years ago what NASA
is paying SpaceX better to bring cargo
up the reason being was they're doing it
more sustainably the matter than if it
can't all be successes he tried SpaceX
and they tried Tesla and Tesla worked
out and maybe SpaceX space has made
space cargo travel sustainable before
when NASA was doing it they would blow
[ __ ] up to that miss fear for to send
cargo to space and they would split off
and the rocket would fall to the earth
and be destroyed
it was super wasteful it was super
expensive but SpaceX their big
innovation was that they made a way for
the rocket itself to be able to land
itself and be reused okay fair enough
that's cool right so that's what they
did and that's why NASA no longer does
it themselves because it's way cheaper
to pay SpaceX to do well but but for me
even if it wasn't a success so what
sometimes someone's gotta try something
but it well the government's not doing
space yeah doing it anymore
so Jeff Bay so right so he lawns like
I'll do it and he's doing it well and II
didn't do it well then oh well he tried
I mean it's like I don't know it seems
like a part of freedom to me I don't
understand but also short-sighted just
write it off because in a hundred years
from now we are mining resources from
asteroids which there's like there's a
infinite resources on asteroids in our
orbit and with SpaceX and the technology
is developing we can mine these
asteroids and basically unlock unlimited
resource
for our planet here on earth of finite
resources same with the moon landing
people said it was a waste of time and
money but it's like it's a technological
revolution that's what he's doing I mean
I think that it's short-sighted to judge
something like that without looking far
ahead at what it can accomplish but but
that's just one case I mean I don't know
what every billionaire is up to I mean
he's very public example but there you
go in your world of Bernie Sanders
billionaire shouldn't exist
Elon Musk can't do what he's doing you
may not have a peddler yeah and then
we'd have a bunch of gas cars still like
dude that's a huge as a huge
contribution to the welfare of the
planet populating electric vehicles
Warren Buffett is a good one isn't it
Warren Buffett yeah he's gonna donate
his whole well I don't know what he's
actively doing for the betterment of
mankind but he's going to donate all of
his wealth when he dies Warren Buffett
is like a little autists to likes
investing it's not evil though he's like
a Rain Man in real life damn what do you
say about my Elon Musk example I mean
that's fine I I started this with saying
that Yulan is kind of a unique case I
would agree that you know he's throwing
his money into some things that
theoretically are gonna better mankind
but um but that's that's you gotta allow
for there's gonna be mistakes and
there's gonna be victories someone not
good and there's gonna be an Elon Musk
you know it's just you can't control
this stuff yeah go ahead Dan what were
you gonna say well just I mean I get
where you're coming from with him but I
mean even in your explanation about
SpaceX stuff you we're talking about how
the moon landing people said it was a
waste but you disagree with that and you
think that it was driving things forward
or whatever and that was done publicly
and communally rather than by you know
look being dictated from the top down by
a single person who ever wants to do a
go for it I mean the government's not
doing this [ __ ]
right well I said when right you think
you should and I do too and it would be
good if we were still investing in those
kind of things but years and years of
austerity and budget cuts and you know
lack of investment in science and
development and those things disappear
well setup me with billionaires not
billionaires not gonna change yeah
that's just shitty government I mean but
Yvonne's doing it because of the lack
because of those things because we're
because the government isn't doing it
well the government the government
sucking doesn't I mean the government
would always neglect some important
point of research and development so
he's just filling in the gap I think the
government just wastes a lot of [ __ ]
money because of corruption or
incompetence or whatever whatever I mean
like corruption
you've got military that's all
corruption dude that money you spend so
much money over that it just disappears
the drug companies that's also
corruption like the all this lobbying
and [ __ ] we were wasting all of our
money just making these people rich now
and it's great I mean Ernie wants to
reduce the budget of like a trillion
dollars I agree but but but don't Satan
billionaire shouldn't exist I will
continue to say the billionaire's
shouldn't but you just admitted that
they but but I didn't mitt anything I
said that sure Elon has done some
positive things I don't think that
really discounts the broader point here
I feel like it's kind of rhetoric though
that can really lead to to fanatics
doing stupid things you know billionaire
shouldn't exist it implies that they're
inherently evil do you know what I mean
I guess I mean you can take it that way
I'm not calling for them to be killed I
just know you're not as you're saying
kind of I mean that's why we're saying
it's a dangerous statement yeah that's
why it's a slippery slope
anyway I voted for Bernie I just think
you that that's the one thing I don't
like because this whole eat the rich
mentality because while I agree people
there's people are way too [ __ ] rich
right but the whole demonizing them is
is not the right way you have to fix
this you
fix this within the system of government
that's broken I mean that's what he's
talking about doing I mean what does he
I mean again are we talking about you
know guillotine people well it's just
the way you talk about it like if you
ask young about it you wouldn't say yeah
they shouldn't exist you would say it's
fortunate that they exist but it's not a
billionaire damn he's richest bernie
yeah yeah but he's also a capitalist to
his core and yeah he doesn't believe in
that no but the point is that they kind
of believe in the same thing but there
is a different way of phrasing it I'm
presenting an argument that could be
toxic where you say they just shouldn't
exist or what yang is saying is a lot
more accepting but he would want to
correct it let's get some of their money
and use it for us yeah it's not saying
that they shouldn't exist yeah yeah
someone asked yang in the Town Hall they
go should someone like Mike Bloomberg be
able to spend three hundred million
dollars on their own campaign he said
yes I do think so there's a capitalist
society he gets spend his money on
whatever he wants yeah ultimately you
can't buy yourself the presidency it has
diminishing returns right at a certain
point you're just gonna start annoying
people like it can only do so much for
you so and and frankly I do agree with
that tape I agree I don't think mine I
don't Bloomberg's not stealing the first
of all the only reason Bloomberg's
trending is because he actually has
credentials look at somebody like Tom
Steyer who's standing close to the same
amount and nobody [ __ ] cares about
Tom Steyer
he's not spending anywhere close dude he
spent like you know he defend 200
million Wow get your facts man get your
facts a he spent two hundred million
dollars that's nowhere close to what
Bloomberg has outspent all of the other
candidates dude I'm he has spent tens of
millions of dollars dan it was just a
hundred a second ago is it tens or
hundreds hundreds of millions that's
what I meant to say look it up dude tell
me get my facts straight
Tom story has spent I would say half as
much as Bloomberg which is two hundred
million versus four hundred million
that guy is spent as much money as yeah
two hundred million do I have my facts
straight
this is from January 17th Bloomberg has
spent 200 million is that you're talking
about now Bloomberg I spent a million
right Stiers spent a hundred
twenty-three where are you could I say
200 this is NPR what are you reading but
my point is that he spends he spent ten
hundreds of millions of dollars that's a
lot of money and nobody [ __ ] cares
about him that is true so are my facts
straight
well again Blume I was still correct
Bloomberg has spent more than all do you
think that if if steyr spent the same
amount as Bloomberg he'd be pulling the
same know everybody knows her stories he
bought every ad he could Bloomberg is
trending because he has a political
experience he has name recognition and
and and people like him people who I
know a lot of New Yorkers that like
Bloomberg and so it's not that you can
just buy the election like Tom Sawyer's
the case in point
I spent let's say he spent at least a
hundred million dollars he spent two
hundred million that's what I've heard
but nobody [ __ ] cares about him so so
I think that's a good point you can't
buy an election I mean you could get
pretty close no but bloom you know and
Bloomberg's still not gonna get it in
either you know so there you go and
Trump on the other hand didn't spend any
money so I mean you so I mean the
evidence shows that you cannot buy an
election because both the guys are
failing what did you mean about Trump
though you didn't spend any money
well he didn't spend that much money did
he he didn't spend much of his own money
if that's what you mean like the way the
Bloomberg is well he raised money and
ton of it yeah and and well anyway my
point is that I agree with Andrew that
they can do spend the money however they
want but this notion that they can buy
elections this kind of materially false
because they're failing to buy the
election both of them
hope you're right about that is anyone
want to chime in Zack and in silence
radio silence no silence nobody's
fighting nobody wants to get into the
[ __ ] I don't want to copy all this
yeah I'm not touching this one man well
I appreciate but this is a good
conversation right I mean look I voted
Bernie I would make that clear you know
I like everything I I generally agree
with all of his policies like Medicare
for all free college like prison reform
all this [ __ ] reducing military spending
I'm down with all that [ __ ] you just
don't agree that it's a moral violation
or wrong for somebody to be a bill in
there yeah one metric that doesn't mean
anything do you understand what I'm
saying like if you follow all the rules
you can still become a billionaire so
why are we demonizing billionaires and
by the way there's a big difference
between 1 billion in one hundred and
thirty billion right yeah there's an
even bigger difference between 2 million
and sixty billion yeah which is why I
agree Sanders isn't isn't like he's not
like I mean he's wealthy 202 million
dollars a lot but he's not rich right so
you still stand by the statement that
billionaires shouldn't exist yeah all
conversation yes I absolutely do and
you're not gonna convince me otherwise
and so are you willing to kill a
billionaire take his money by force I
mean all power is violence and so I mean
no I don't I don't want to kill them but
you know if they don't want to pay their
taxes they can go to jail like anybody
else would I agree
but that's not what's that the question
at hand let's say somebody take all the
rules let's say somebody follows all the
rules mm-hmm everything we've got all
these new taxes and everything and then
somebody still manages to make 50
billion dollars he's paying his workers
really what you'd like Jeff
Bezos for example he pays let's say he
gives everyone a raise great salary
great benefits he starts paying taxes
like he's supposed to
he's still gonna be worth like 50
billion dollars because he's worth 130
now so he's still gonna be mega wealthy
even if he does all those things what
she should do it by the way yeah but so
what happens then you got a guy worth 50
billion dollars and he's following all
your rules I mean I think if he followed
all the rules he wouldn't I don't I
don't buy into your scenario he wouldn't
have 50 billion dollars you don't think
seventy billion dollars would go far
enough to do all that [ __ ] I mean not if
he's I'm not if we implement a wealth
tax not if we're you know actually
implementing progressive tax rates I
mean so how high does the highest
regressive tax rate go uh I mean I don't
know off the top of my head well just
give me an idea because by the way this
tax plan that Bernie put forward is caps
at 52% federally caps at 52% over like
you know what over like quarter million
or something yeah exactly so every
dollar over a quarter million you're
paying and that's the two cents on that
dollar and that's the highest tax
bracket yeah okay so Bernie disagrees
with you apparently wait what what do
you mean he's highest tax bracket he's
proposing is fifty two percent on anyone
over a quarter million doesn't he also
want to implement a wealth tax oh I
don't know I mean I was assumed that the
brackets would just go on the tax where
it's like if you make over a million
then it's this much but the wealth tax
was on I don't know what I don't know if
that's separate I don't know I believe
that that's separate that's what you're
talking about his income down what's the
wealth tax tell me about that well tax
what it's like what's he proposing two
percent somebody looked that up I want
to say Ernie is saying two percent well
tax for money over like 20 million or
something like that's not that bad that
won't prevent billionaires over the last
thirty two million and
not worth of less than sorry I was also
kind of like making sure I'm reading the
right thing it applies to 30 million 32
million and up of net words and what's
the tax I'm reading as I'm trying to
understand I want to say I remember yeah
here tax rate would increase to 2% on
net worth from 50 to 250 million 3% from
250 to 500 million 4% from 500 million
to a billion and 5% from 1 to 2.5
billion it keeps going up it looks like
it puts the highest at 8% over 10
billion that's not gonna prevent
billionaires either I mean this is
annually yeah I mean yeah obviously the
rhetoric of billionaires shouldn't exist
is is just that it's rhetoric I mean
there will be outlier scenarios but
certainly by clamping down on the
extreme ends of the wealth inequality in
this country will at least compress that
number and yeah I mean people like Jeff
Bezos or Michael Bloomberg who have
these just really unfathomable amounts
of money like like hard to wrap your
mind around like more money than anybody
like could ever spend in a lifetime type
of money right
bringing that down to from a hundred and
twenty billion or whatever Jeff Bezos
capped at I know we lost a bunch because
of his divorce right but I think at his
back yeah I'm sure he's bounced back
what's that one song I took an L
nighttime bounce back
that's Bezos you know if you get that
dude down to two or three billion
dollars which is still again like more
money than you could spend if you were
like trying to spend it all type them
that's not true by the way at that high
end when you're talking about like big
tech moves like Elon Musk you a couple
billion dollars isn't enough money but
we're talking about individual wealth I
mean he messed his own money to make
this [ __ ] I'm sure he does but he also
has a lot of investors why should he
need investors if he's got them the
resources to do it himself
and then what's where while these
resources in Wester come from if there's
all this huge tax on their money
like is that you can't generate enough
money you need like let's say twenty
billion dollars to make Tesla I feel
like that's an exaggeration I mean it's
not people are still gonna have wealth I
mean it's not going to eliminate wealth
altogether we've had a very long
conversation about this we can move on
but my point is that I don't like those
statements I think they're dangerous
billionaires shouldn't exist we need
more nuance than that yeah agree to
disagree
I feel like you just agreed with me the
whole time
then you weren't listening to anything I
was saying didn't you like the whole
time about a fact we agree about the
concept of taxing and regulating and all
that stuff but just stretching sorry all
right let's move on yeah 20:25 I
begrudgingly voted for Bernie honestly I
I was I begrudgingly I'm not a hundred
percent Bernie but I voted for him
because I know you're you said you were
considering between him and Bloomberg
right well I wanted to see how Bloomberg
did in the debate and he ate [ __ ] so I
just I want to fall in line now I want
to support the party that's what I want
to do and I do like Bernie I like his
policies I don't want to see what he can
do in office so I I support Bernie I
mean currently to me bernie is the best
option yes I want to angle more yeah but
it never happened for yangban listen
here's the reality is that with all this
stuff the the whole strategy and I mean
they'll never like say this out loud
because you got to like stick to your
line or whatever but for so long the
Democrats have always just been about
compromise and meeting in the middle in
yada-yada-yada and that's why we get
these like very like incremental or you
know think things like Obamacare which
is like you know it's objectively better
than the situation from before but
nobody's really happy with it kind of
solutions and I think what's good about
his rhetoric and saying things like
billionaires shouldn't exist is like
obviously billionaires are gonna
continue to exist in this country it's
not going to be able to eliminate
billionaires but when you start from
that point you know ideologically then
when you inevitably meet in the middle
because that is what politics and the
country is about is about compromise
you're compromising in a place that's
like on your own terms instead of always
I just think the rhetorics dangerous
yeah well I mean I hear what you're
saying but ultimately you got to be
careful about about the words you use
because well it's crazy find out you're
worried about getting dragged out to the
park and getting your head lobbed off
you told us that the other day well and
I told you because you voted for Bernie
you have a pass you're good right we're
not gonna just remember I voted for
Bernie next art guillotine by the way
I'm not that rich I mean I'm I'm wealthy
but I'm not rich you're like Bernie
wealthy yes
I'm burning well there you go he's got
more houses than you he yes yeah so what
the [ __ ] he doesn't live in LA yeah he
broke but but those three houses
combined might be one house in LA so
we've we've talked about a lot here and
who I hate hates politics me do you know
what I know I've actually liked it I
like know but lately cuz I feel like
it's like the counterculture is like
[ __ ] shut up shut up over here
politics until the TV everywhere going
here's a late night shut up it's so
everybody avoids it nobody talks about
but here that's why I like it I like
when people actually express how they
feel it's refreshing because I I like
when people I care about actually talk
about what they think it's it's
refreshing and therefore I like talking
about it I mean I guess I mean it's not
political show but hates I enjoyed the
part about the man is in the hair more
we've got it all I mean the the thing
this is you know I get why people get
fatigued by it I get why they don't want
to hear about it it's all over the place
but um you know I think a lot of people
have really woken up in the last since
since 2016 it's been a wake-up call to a
lot of people that like these things
matter and they have kind of like a
direct material impact on how we live
our lives like how things are going in
the world and you know Dan is woke you
can't I mean you just say well you can't
ignore it I mean I hate the whole woke
culture and all that [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
annoying as hell but you know as far as
becoming politically aware maybe more
than what we all right that's enough
politics Jase stations all channel was
demonetized there's no link here you
like your phone is making I just heard
the proof against it what another I
heard the sound but it's on there look I
don't care about the mom I'm he's still
hearing silence happening you got turned
your [ __ ] phone off well was room for
my craft I don't have a link to Jays
station do monitor
that's so weird but anyway Jay station
oh he made a video called goodbye so Jay
station YouTube actually demonetized
this whole channel isn't that epic like
one day do you monetize logan paul after
suicide force yeah
so they
they enacted the same it's like imminent
uh is that wartime rules what do they
call that when they can like take over
your house during war and it's oh my or
during our show wha Marsh well it's like
martial law yeah let's say that
YouTube's about this martial law rule so
they do monetize this whole Channel so
awesome he goes I really lost who I was
in pursuit of success I don't know how
long I'm gonna take a break for could be
a week could be a month could be here I
here I'm calling it right now
I guarantee he'll take a week a break
for two weeks which is the amount of
time he's been demonetized and I'll be
back the day he can earn money again
what's up guys so this video is like
only I'm usually only on a guy like this
fine success did you'll be back in two
weeks enjoy your vacation with you guys
just listen to me listen to me and
remember I said this does he know how
long he has two weeks he knows that they
do him that yes hmm
so he's just saying that he's taking a
break so what YouTube does is they say
you get two weeks of no monetization and
in that time you need to remove all your
videos shredder what's up with you
here it says you Jay station will have
the opportunity to regain monetization
YouTube says what the broad caveat that
he must address all revelant is relevant
issues with this channel for
comparison's sake in the case of Logan
Paul pre-roll ads return to Paul's
channel roughly two weeks after
YouTube's suspended them though he
remained on probation for ninety days
remaining he was ineligible to appear on
trending I've been on probation my whole
life to [ __ ] meaning he's ineligible to
appear on trending or in any
notification from non subscribers whoa
how long have I how long have I been on
probation ten years so anyway just
remember I said this he's gonna be back
in exactly two weeks when he gets ads
back so enjoy your vacation J station
ninja
kind of I haven't got to anything how
long have we been going I likely haven't
talked about anything yeah like an hour
15 hour 20 or so mm-hmm yeah we're hit
some random about 41 minutes and the
first half plus the break was about 40
yes about an hour 20 mm-hmm somewhere
around there feels longer sounds like
I'm having a lot of fun doesn't it um
ninja
controversial tweet alert controversial
tweet alert alert alert alert alert some
what y'all think about this let's have a
group discussion what's with this guy
eating a sandwich I'm curious what he
has to say I'm gonna get back to him in
a minute he says he tweets out the
phrase it's just a game it's such a weak
mindset you are okay with what happened
losing in perfection of a craft when you
stop getting angry after losing you've
lost twice there's always something to
learn a no it's room for improvement
never settle well before I call an
action one wash it was so we're talking
about 2:00 this morning I am eating a
sandwich right now
that [ __ ] was so returned about to
respond in another language what does
sweater leave me alone
somebody let trigger so what do you
think about that tweet so when I when I
first saw it and there was trending and
everyone was like [ __ ] on him I my
first reaction was that I didn't really
get it like what's who cares I'm not
again yeah I really get what's the big
deal about what I said because to me
having grown up playing video games
raging is like the saddest most pathetic
thing you could do and that's when you
hate yourself the most because you
should so I guess I don't even really
know what's raging it's so toxic when
you grow up playing online video games
the the raging toxic mentality is just
it ruined it can ruin the game and so
what I see is a dude that has anger
problems with his game and he's trying
to justify yeah getting angry I mean I
don't think he says when you stop
getting angry after losing you've lost
twice I don't think most professional
athletes would agree I think being Zen
and accepting her loss and and I even
killed kind of you know a from Zen
approach was way more healthy they're
getting angry I think if you get angry
you've lost twice I think he's got it
backwards and it's just a game I mean
it's not a weak mindset I don't know why
you say that those look at all these
mean so it goes on but the more I read
it it just feels kind of crazy the whole
statement I don't know he says yes I
agree oh here's a video of him
explaining himself let's see this is the
excuse it's just a gimmick
if anyone ever uses the excuse it's just
a game I'm gonna lose my mind imagine
telling LeBron James Tom Brady that one
that there one that when their stall off
after losing game that it's just a game
like I'm gonna lose like are you kidding
me you're so stupid it's about the
competitive nature bro
it's about respect about pride it's so
much bigger than a video game I can't
really get past the blue hair I'm being
honest it's a horrible human being it is
lazy really you're a little lazy human
being you know that's lazy well anyway
is funny because he said imagine LeBron
James saying it's just a game and the
guys actually found a quote of LeBron
saying and I don't think anyone why are
the dogs going wild shredder you killing
me shredder you're killing me I don't
think anyone will argue that LeBron
James isn't a better athlete than ninja
but LeBron James claims basketball is
just a game he says and I'm more
comfortable about it because it's just a
game I prepare myself I'm gonna go out
and do my job and live with the results
see that's an elevated athlete that's a
guy who's worked on his mental game
because the mental game is super
important you got to make sure you keep
your [ __ ] together
yeah because ultimately this is just a
game otherwise he's got angry and anger
as we all know was the dark side of the
force
did you know that no but I get it so
LeBron James disagrees with ninja
interesting I guess that's first I just
didn't really I saw it and I didn't
think about it twice and I was like why
is everyone freaking out about this I
mean it's not that big of a deal he's
just kind of douchey but but yeah also
he's a rager like he has a lot of
moments where he's like a lot of the
sound bites you hear is him raging but I
just feel like I I don't think this is a
good thing to tell kids because there is
a big problem with kids raging and it's
not healthy to say that it's just a game
as a weak mindset alright then it's a
lazy that's stupid you think if you
don't
get angry you're lazy than you than your
lazy ass ain't what I don't want all
these kids walk around all agree over
for tonight hmm
you know what I mean it's definitely
just a game dude would I would you ever
say this is just a podcast how dare you
ever say that to me after the Bill burr
episode would you say it's just a
podcast it's a way of life it's so much
more than that
there's a coronavirus story in the news
there's a hotel and I don't know in
Italy but with the so crazy good guy
with a thousand guests I think it said
and someone there tested positive for
Corona and they quarantined the whole
[ __ ] hotel this stuff is like my
nightmare when when people talk
somewhere now like this hotel a thousand
people the people that are stuck on the
cruise ship the cruise is the worst
nightmare there's nothing to the cruise
is the worst that's so much worse tiny
little rooms in the hotel life now
you're stuck in a tiny room phobic you
know you don't have your stuff you just
stuck we do feel quite isolated shut up
that's what you get for going on
vacation that's what you get for going
on vacation interest by the way people
that accent
okay sorry here let's finish it let's
finish it I take it back I'm so sorry to
them there my heart goes out to them we
have a number I had with reception to
see what's happening but we've got to
know water I'm sure they'll get a motor
but you know what's funny all these
people on the cruise ships they got
trapped I'm like that's what you get for
going on a cruise on a cruise I would
agree
but these guys are just in Italy that's
what you get for going to Italy so I saw
a picture of the of the note they sent
like they slipped it under everyone's
door and they Barney should run on no
cruises should exist that's a good
platform that's a really good platform
let's get rid of the cruise let's sink
all cruise ships yeah so ninja ninja
baka da da da
also do you guys agree with my take can
we get some hot eggs from the backstage
on the ninja to you yeah yeah it's
cringy as oh like it's it is just a game
shut up dude it's for night bro yeah not
a big deal especially I mean everything
that he's saying and trying to compare
it to like real sports it's like maybe
you would have an argument if like you
were was in like a tournament or
something that were like something's on
the line but if you're just like
streaming playing game it's too like the
equivalent be like LeBron James like
freaking out and punching drywall for
losing in a practice corny that looks
like when professional athletes go
raging I mean that's such a bad luck
yeah it's like it's like imagine chess
players every time they lose they just
flip the board the thing is I mean he
was obviously heated although I guess he
followed the tweets yeah he did stand by
it I mean that's stupid thing to stand
by I mean overall what he's saying about
like you should learn from your
experience and like like you should be
passionate like he was just using the
word passion instead of anger it would
probably come across a lot better that's
not what he meant
I know but he doubled down yeah it's
like no you should be [ __ ] pissed off
and it's like he's gotta remember kids
the kids are watching him like I'm when
I used to get angry like that over video
games it's just so embarrassing it's so
much self-loathing and you'll have to
self load that's not acceptable behavior
he's trying to encourage people to
embrace this attitude and not hate
yourself for raging over a video game
you should hate yourself is not good
behavior yeah thank you
thank you everybody next story oh and
then this whole ninja I have more ninja
news are you interested you mm-hmm ninja
was hacked and then he tweeted at this
other fortnight player fight me
and then the whole other fortnight
player made this all budget it was
obviously hacked and so now this other
fortnight player was really popular to
wants to fight him for real now but
backer said yeah and he knows it was a
hacker so now he made like a video being
like I want to fight ninja I got like I
got beef with it and like near not man
enough to fight minutes like dude he
didn't tweet it to you but he knows that
so are you interested in that story mmm
no okay
Paul Jake Paul gets body slammed by gigi
hadid
Noah cookin now we're cooking it's Jacob
all the most irredeemable person on
YouTube right yeah Jake about J station
we just talked well J station is such a
concentrated son bag Jake Paul is action
out there trying to actually scam kids
and tell him not to go to school like
you can't talk yeah the greedy [ __ ] the
greeting Nick Paul said now he's talking
about Zayn from one direction he said
almost had to clap up Zayn I'm assuming
that means like punch clap up the end
you know that mean gonna clap those
cheeks yeah clap his cheeks Oh for real
like slap him spank his ass or his face
slap the fan give it a nice little space
giving a little red bottom okay almost
had to clap up Zayn from one direction
because he's a little guy i'll tall is
he uh look that up or is he talking
about his build because Jake is now a
professional boxer he was five nine
Oh on the shorter side so he so he
tweets out he's a little guy I mean god
you're such a douchebag
there's dias it's like what's wrong dude
and has an attitude and basically told
me to [ __ ] off
no reason when I was being nice to him
saying I know you're reading this stop
being angry because you came home alone
to your big-ass hotel room ha ha ha
can you imagine like Jake Paul boom like
assuming people want to hang out with
him he's so embarrassing like he is like
imagine if Zane hung out with Jake Paul
he would lose so much street credibility
besides the fact of actually hanging out
with Jake Paul which in this of itself
is just an awful night I mean welcome to
if he wants to but I don't know Justin
Bieber apparently was hanging out with
them on this and also let me also say
super embarrassing super embarrassed but
this tweet I want that yummy yummy I
wonder if he wrote that song in Logan
Paul's locker room I want that yummy
yummy yummy and then he follows it up I
bro he literally started yelling and
freaking the [ __ ] out you want to test
me mate well I feel bad for childhood
stars okay so that's Jake Bohm wait no I
kind of I think he wishes he was no he
was on Disney yeah he kind of is wait
I'm fine he was like wasn't I'd i
apprec-- here but he was on bizarre
barkal and like two years ago yeah but
he wasn't a child yeah kind of like that
but Zane wasn't a childhood star he was
like the same age as Jake when Jake is
not far from a childhood star let's just
say that he's as far as as Zane is cuz
did they get famous like on the singing
competition One Direction x-factor yeah
an x-factor and then I think they were
probably 16 17 18 years old so Jake was
by the same definition a child star I
definitely agree with you
that it's ironic then Gigi Hadid who is
the girlfriend of Zayn came over the top
eight hundred and thirty thousand likes
in a response not even a retweet or
anything this is great response she said
law because he doesn't care to hang with
you and you're embarrassing crew of
YouTube groupies I feel like that is
such an apt description of what yeah
what's going on yeah home alone with his
best friends like a respectful King cuz
he has me sweetie unbothered by her
irrelevant ugly ass go to bed yep and
that common actually went viral and beat
his ass into such swift and harsh
submission the next day he erased his
original tweets and said someone needs
to take my phone when I'm drunk because
I'm a [ __ ] idiot well I'm afraid that
that may not have to do with the alcohol
that you're also [ __ ] it we were
sober yeah I think he also on purpose
like me spelled his name like he doesn't
know how to spells Nia Jake is the worst
I mean he really is the worst I think
he's my least favorite person on the
planet right now because of that holes
you make money scam the scamming things
real but then this whole entitlement of
like being entitled to this dude's
attention because he didn't want to hang
out with you I mean dude okay your
[ __ ] call us someone a little guy
especially when you are actually not a
little bit like someone like Jake which
is pretty fit and probably pretty tall I
don't know we met him he's like the same
height as me maybe it's right it's all
her so six foot I'm calling someone else
a little guy is an insult is like the
worst thing you can do in my opinion
it's just you look so bad I don't know
just so spiteful yeah it's got this
poison in him to say something like that
below the belt yeah but I don't like it
I think he's just bitterly jealous
because Zayn is actually famous actually
talented actually is dating a model and
is respected and it and he he's just so
that's what he want
so bad and meanwhile he's dating Tana
mangu if you could imagine Joe I guess
it's pronounced Mongoose it is no I
don't know but imagine dude he's dating
Tana yeah I would want to [ __ ] be
drunk every night - damn
are they still think I already saw
pictures of Logan with her oh yeah now
Logan's [ __ ] her isn't the best well
that was like a spoof no that's real
yeah they were ever really dating I feel
like it's everything that I would
honestly rather pierce I would rather
give myself a what do you call that when
you pierce the tip of your penis
Prince Albert yeah I would rather give
myself watch Albert than hang out what I
didn't always call her Prince Albert I
don't know where that comes from
wait is Albert the one that hangs out
with Epstein no that's Andrew Michael
Bloomberg that's right Brad Brad
whatever that guy hung up with everybody
it's dad he's like he's a New York
social yeah yeah he's in New York
socialite hung out with everything he's
taking a picture with every notable
person in New York like I mean if you
find one picture of them together that
doesn't mean that Bloomberg is full he
was in his rolodex - yeah multiple
contact numbers tell me about it
I just did okay that's not enough to
convict him and say there's a [ __ ] no he
may be a crazy sick oh you said creep
yeah yeah that he's a [ __ ] for some
reason did he make a good crab gangsta
he's an anti crypt he took all their
guns right so that's Gigi Hadid Gigi
mega dude it's more like Gigi Jake Paul
you know I'm saying good game
mega dudu that was pretty badass he's
probably he's probably like oh yeah cuz
he don't want to answer cuz it's like
below him he's like this is just so
stupid that this kids tweeting at me and
then GG came in like like you know why
aren't you blessed you do blast out
tweets like this for me when people come
yeah you do you write no either right I
love no no yeah you're a queen like Gigi
Hadid it hasn't happened in a long time
but I have done that's true you have
Ryder died for me did you guys both know
who gigi hadid was when he saw this I
did she's been yeah ever since I'm like
more into fashion I kind of know no
that's true well you know I didn't know
maybe like a year ago I didn't either
but I see I see what's her sister's name
Bella I see Bella Hadid everywhere right
we're both supermodels or you know but
no right I didn't know there was two of
them till recently I didn't know there
was two of them until this tweet I was
like but she's mega famous like she has
so many followed I know I was blown away
it just shows how out of touch I am like
this person has like 30 million I'm kind
of in the same boat as you cuz I was
well aware of Bella Hadid I think
they're also part of their like
Kardashian crew and all those the Hadid
ISM that summer I think that mom was
famous
so deeds they're part of those I did
their dad is a like he's a rich [ __ ] but
he's broke now because he went belly-up
on this one construction project in Bel
Air that they tore down yeah read about
that and the brother is dating one of
the biggest pop stars right now what pop
star do a Lipa oh yeah you could say her
name
yeah yeah I was just so her dad I read
about this in the paper he was doing one
of these bel-air mega mansions that are
like least 150 million dollar mega
mansions and he didn't get the permits
so the city's like you got to tear the
whole [ __ ] thing down oh yeah look at
that
he was also sentenced to 200 hours of
community
service oh my god that's so community
for a guy like that so their mom is one
of the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
oh my god God sure you're all better
than that let me see a photo ver what's
your name she was also models what's her
name
Yolanda Hadid Yolanda Yolanda Yolanda
Yolanda yeah she's been through the
wringer alright yeah how's Papa this is
the dual mission Papa Ethan I miss pop
every day Jamie get to I thought you
guys were buddies
I'm talkin callin me me which sister is
more attractive in your opinion I
actually don't know them enough to well
here today who is who let me see let me
get up family
remember we thought we there was a whole
thing where they said what's her name
Bella's right scientifically beautiful
personal I agree I think she's more
attractive if I am so wait ballets the
one on the left yeah it's not a great
picture er yeah I guess I think so but
they're both pretty obviously Gigi's the
one on the left
no no Gigi's in the middle you ding-dong
Gigi's in the middle yes oh I guess I
don't know culture no I agree with that
you can see her nips through this one
it's pretty awesome
well I mean what can I do it's mesh
they're not showing it well you guys
didn't show it well it was on screen for
a second ever I think it's fine right
you didn't cut away real fast covered oh
don't ask me we can blur it cut it just
cut it will cut it post cut it's not
worth it they're like yeah well there
was a nipple on the screen at the one
our and 26 minutes and we're going to
monetize and mature rate your entire to
our podcast okay that makes sense make
sense
gigi hadid Wendy Williams is back in the
news we love Wendy Williams Carrie we
all know jus Carrie a host of The Price
is Right and comedian his ex-girlfriend
was murdered
thrown out of a hotel window and this is
Wendy Williams hot topics take it says
hot topics behind her listen closer to
this show monster drew carey's ex-fiance
was tragically murdered over the weekend
look look it was like three o'clock on
Saturday morning uh-huh and there was
screaming in the neighborhood in LA she
lived with a roommate a girl roommate
and the roommate heard the screaming the
neighbors all around the neighborhood
heard the screaming screaming and they
called 9-1-1 once the cops got there she
was down there dead on the ground
yep um was pushed off of a third-floor
balcony I'll give you a little backstory
so she was killed not by drew but by by
the ex oh well so impressive right
Rice's right yeah when they announce
someone gets to compete they say come on
down
so Frank is his ex-fiancee falling off
the balcony that coming on down and
you'll notice the crickets even her like
dude I'll give you a little backstory so
she was killed not by drew but by by the
ex come on down why she's a [ __ ]
nasty piece of work isn't she she's
farted right now there you hear that
listen closely do you hear that I think
she ripped that hear it why are you
putting allegedly the
stories everywhere all right lawyer lady
she threw allegedly in there hasn't been
convicted the ex-boyfriend has the big
bit yeah
I like how they're like allegedly she's
like [ __ ] you he burnt he's a murder I
like how she's like not drew Carey by
the way as if anyone was accusing drew
Carey of murder
so that's Wendy Williams being the worst
there's a tell me what you think about
the Batman suit there's lots of
controversy around the new Batman suit
does that bother you what is the
controversy people think it looks dumb
but this takes place like in the infancy
of Batman I like it I have no problem I
got no problem no problem no problem for
me why is everyone hating everything
Daniel hater play it play it Zach
I do actually hate that cost of - no
it's appropriate why why isn't that bad
I mean it's not bad at all plague Dan
the hater would you do we actually made
that because we wanted Dan to do a
segment dan the hater about goop on
Netflix but we decided that it's not
even worth it for a whole well I
uploaded some test footage and it
immediately got ranked struck yeah so
and I'm so afraid of them removing
global worldwide that I'm like that's
just it's such a nightmare yeah that's
stupid
well New York time Oh Bennet there's a
big announcement the pic of Ben Affleck
statu you uh the worst tattoo ela says
ever played on a man's stars had become
my favorite tattoo what what does that
mean just cuz I so iconic at this point
it's so awful well he said it really is
off a story came out and he lied about
not having it that's the big story so
yeah he that was part of the calculation
of why I was the worst someone asked him
let's talk about honesty for a minute
shouldn't he have been honest from the
start about the damn back tattoo rather
than telling extra was fake for a movie
he said I resented that somebody got a
picture of me by spying on me
it felt invasive but you're right I
could have said that it's none of your
business I could have said I guess I got
a kick out of messing with extra is your
tattoo real or not real of course it's
real
no I put a fact tattoo on my back then
hit it thoughts it does kind of give me
perspective because I could imagine the
situation now and if I can imagine him
trying to hang out on a personal thing
and someone is like taking a photo that
he didn't want to be out there and then
people ask him is it real and then I can
see him like saying no it's fake you
know like you're just messing with them
yeah like and then that became a whole
story I don't think he was really trying
didn't like how can you deny that that's
real you don't bring it yeah that to to
the beach yeah on that scale so I can
give him a little credit points okay so
is it still the worst I still don't like
it at all it's so big and ugly but I
feel bad for him there you go one simple
statement cleared everything up so is
goat hole or the qaol or no that one
Israeli guy with the eyes on the back of
it yeah I guess that way bigger than Ben
Affleck though well I'm we're almost to
the end here I've got a couple of goofs
of Fame that we've been building up on
my new rapid-fire hair Flat Earth Cyril
wife walks in on him doing a riveting
this is not to scale of course
the pump could not the earth Millie
added bail no they give me like five
minutes she's freezing and hungry by the
way if I can make this story even better
this was uploaded by him on his channel
called life with a globe Arthur on Flat
Earth saying look how I'm discriminated
by globe Arthur's I feel like anyone who
starts talking about a librarian should
be hit with this can you cut the fact
with you
yeah Barry seems to be [ __ ] married
one of these people awesome we've got
one kiss tribute bands hair catches on
fire watch the music here Zack thank you
it's done this is the most metal thing
ever there's a guy playing guitar on
stage pyrotechnics go off his hair is so
laden with hairspray it catches on fire
there's a full blown infernal on his
head straight up smoldering Flint his
head there's a huge flame on his head he
is still playing music has not stopped
the roadies come comes slamming in from
the side with a fire extinguisher
put out the fire redo his hair and he
never stopped playing never batted an
eye his hair his head was on fire and he
played through it
medals how medal is that be unbelievable
thing you could pull that off Zack I
could try it flame on his head the
danger of hairspray yes
what is this third I did not label this
video so I'm clicking oh yeah look at
this bro you go my god the Crown Prince
of Dubai just posted this he said a
major milestone and the quest to achieve
100% autonomous human flight the
milestone is about speed and altitude so
there's some dude and a jetpack
one dude one jetpack one dream and he
just he's on at work and jumped off he's
floating and then he just lies the [ __ ]
off and what I am fascinated by he just
flies the [ __ ] off thank God and he's
like dude and then my like there's no
explanation where he went how deal and
that guy's dead it's Team Rocket dude yo
that's a one-way flight I love that like
how your land is like the biggest yeah
it's easy to put on check that [ __ ]
blow your blow away but actually that
reminds me and this kind of ties in with
the first video that you just saw did
you see the story yesterday about the
flat earther dude who just killed
himself
no why he kill himself not by not on not
intentionally didn't commit suicide he
was you may have seen him in the news
he's a flat earther who built a rocket a
homemade rocket to go up to a high
enough elevation to be able to take his
own photos to prove that the earth is
flat well he did a test over the weekend
a test flight and he smashed his
homemade rocket so they take an airplane
you could have you could have just not
been trying to prove that the earth is
flat and [ __ ] wrong you could have
just listened this guy at a pumpkin in
his kitchen yeah it's not scale some
people are meant for greatness and they
I love that the Crown Prince of Dubai is
just this is his vibe he's just I want
when I was an autonomous human flight
this is extraordinary this is not
extraordinary this is this is a dude who
just committed suicide look at this
peace is a guy everybody
what
no all right so shout out to Dubai who
was uh who's really making it happen out
there the roll patrol who know this is a
video that really tickled my buns love
the roll but we've been [ __ ] quoting
this at the office for the last week so
I'll just play this for you is there
sound or so this is some dude who has
like a hidden case in Rob's you know
there's like a bread section in Rob's
and there's some homie oh it looks like
he's sitting in a like mobility scooter
shopping cart and he's filming this dude
grab a roll so here you go
am i right that he's in a mobility
scooter what's so low the camera so low
okay I'm sorry I paused it and I missed
the the crime take place he smells the
roll throws it back in
you you specially use the wax paper when
you touch the rolls I'm broke patrol
dude ah you supposed to use a wax paper
and you're sniffing them and then you're
touching them and put them back they
smell like [ __ ] okay just do me a favor
just pick up the ones you touched and
buy them because I don't want I don't
want I don't know where your dick
beaters been me pick them the [ __ ] up
and put them in your bag or I'm gonna
even you up he's sitting look where his
finger was he's definitely sitting it's
not sitting but look why is the camera
so low and then here he stands up like
like blushes that's name I'm ruining the
video for view 11 it sounds low pick up
the football watch this finger in your
bag or I'm gonna even you up I'm Tony
right now I'm gonna even you to [ __ ]
that
watch this pick him up oh he doesn't
stand up I'll trip disgusting I know
when you'd roll baby can you believe how
he got through to that guy
he's like even [ __ ] up I don't know if
we did justice to the video cuz I [ __ ]
it up yeah yeah but it's epic roll
Patrol did we watch it again and me just
sit back or does that ruin it further I
don't know but the guy really did a 180
he goes he goes put that in your bag and
buy it he goes okay he's like it's
[ __ ] disgusting I know it's like some
tough guy mm-hmm
so this guy must have been huge scary
dude the roll Patrol serious business
how do we get ahold of the roll patrol I
want that guy in here as well he scares
me no rough one to find anything
can you guys looking over finding the
roll patrol guy I mean I guess so yeah
what do you what do you want to talk to
roll patrol guy about to but don't I
want to talk to Roberto got about it's
[ __ ] roll but yeah finally I wanted
to get you guys takes on a huge
collaboration between KFC and Crocs the
collaboration everybody's been waiting
for of course is the Kentucky Fried
Chicken X Crocs it looks like a giant
bucket of KFC and it's got a little
trinket of of a fried chicken on the
front it's disgusting
and then they have one oh it's just this
I thought they had a long one because
here in the video they have one that has
like high heels yeah and it's like a
whole bucket it's crazy this promo video
is like super well produced yeah there
yeah you see that like who is buying
this [ __ ] nobody's buying this right
look at the size of those that is awful
I guess no one I got I think the theory
of Crocs is that they're ugly by
definition so they're like the uglier
the better in a way I don't know if that
was their definition when they came out
but I feel like they're just embracing
it no but still those are unwearable by
any definition of the
I mean except for a gag I mean you can't
wear those outside it's like a part of
an outfit a lot of doctors when you
think doctors gonna be wearing the KFC
cross I hope mine does
you think doctors show up more in
crosswalk doctors wear Crocs no Wendy's
dumb oh no no wait doctors wear Crocs
yeah
I'm not sure about that ones I've seen a
lot of chefs wear it chefs make sense
chefs make sense doctors doctors
surgeons yeah sir you sure they like
surgeons wear Crocs like while they're
operating yeah mmm I just googled do
doctors wear Crocs and there's a bunch
of stuff about how doctors work you know
about the doctors in the crop it's just
like a known thing the one that the
chef's were too but it's like it doesn't
have the holes at the front mm-hmm it's
just solid you know at the front door
check out this linkage I didn't realize
Crocs were working in shoes you're
getting the roll patrol ones Oh what the
hell those are hideous I don't like that
show I think it's not a classic cross no
but there is the classic one here let me
show you yeah they were the classic ones
too with holes now it holds yeah exactly
I bought one pair of Crocs in my life
and I left it in the Sun in Vegas and
they shrunk by 50% that's crazy
never same thing like it what is going
on I do not realize crux has the market
card I guess I guess just because I've
never worn Crocs are they comfortable
yeah I never worn it's like really soft
plastic it's all right I mean I guess if
you work on your feet all day why not
there's no scald the specialist clog
specialist to clog but I don't work
clogs
I wear shoes thank you very much hmm
well that's all we've got here guys
that's it we're thinking of skipping on
Friday because
PewDiePie was scheduled and he canceled
and we don't have plans for Friday so
darn but he'll be here next Tuesday yes
awesome can't wait so look forward to
that and but but in all seriousness I
don't we will not be having episode
Friday we were serious about computing
my thing
yeah I'm sorry I didn't mean to I'm
gonna say anyway that we weren't
oh my throat is hurting for talking to
us um so what spongebob will be out on
Thursday the spongebob spongebob
spongebob I really was wild yeah that
done just wait baby crazier [ __ ] there's
a lot of work took a long time just
working with like the corporates the
legal [ __ ] I think the contract okay oh
that's a whole different world you guys
haven't dealt with before yeah oh yeah
it was it was eye-opening but I feel
like we learned a lot and I'm ready for
it next time but um you know we've got
friends at at vikon now in licensing
department so there's like a huge a huge
list of but but we're actually working
on some other collapse now that I'm like
even more excited for I'm trying to
cover the wick I don't know why did you
ever light it no yeah I noticed that bad
job baby
alright Premium bring in fire there's a
come on
Alfredo's over it you just sitting there
staring at me buddy do we are we gonna
go to teddy fresh he'll are we or are we
gonna go home we are it's actually close
to the time we gotta go home oh wow it's
already oh [ __ ]
so can we just not even go there I'm
just gonna stop by because once you stop
by it turns into a hole I have to stop
right why CEO Ethan I have to stop by
what's going on okay no see what's what
fires I need to yeah but didn't you end
up staying for too long you
in there 439 well I know don't worry I
got no kind of no option dear door all
right I mean we've got the candle
burning how's it smell I mean it's a
generic candle yeah there's just a
generic handle there was a lot of smell
when we took it out of the box but I
feel like now it's just it's a doll left
it's just a candle generica that doesn't
even ever smell I mean it's just a
generic you know most candles are
perfumed and it has this perfumey smell
it has a perfume but it's very much less
now than it was when we took rose I mean
that's my defining smell rose and it's
nice this you know but it's just a grand
now it's just a candle candle smell nice
yeah you guys you got to see the dogs
they're both just staring at me now you
guys wanted to come you guys usually
stay at home but you wanted to come so
no you're living with the consequence
yeah we're wrapping it up all right so
guys we will not be seeing you on
Saturday I apologize I am so sorry for
that but blame blame Beauty fine there
are certain factors are out of control
send in your applications the
Bachelorette is exciting
yeah so we'll follow up on that next
week and until then have a fantastic
week a fantastic weekend you are truly
the best and we love you just so much so
much okay open
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]